I want people to drink six dollar  coffees if they can afford it I don't  want them to buy it when they can't  saving money is incredibly important  living within your means is incredibly  important and more importantly having a  job you hate or doing something you hate  just to pay for stuff to make pretend  you're happy that's the worst of them  all you know with the potential of a  global recession in the air saving money  as I've been talking about forever  has become more important than ever I  really hope people heated that call two  years ago whether you're buying luxury  goods like clothes cars Vacations or  whether you're investing in high risk  Investments like  nfts Collectibles uh stock market that  you can afford to use things are awesome  and if anything all this fear bud in the  market really shakes a lot of you I  promise you saving money is always